I really I really fall apart if I don't
exercise Journal meditate and go to
therapy I fall apart pretty [__]
quickly unravel yeah I have anxiety you
know I have anxiety disorder do you take
any uh anxiety medication sometimes like
I'll take a Xanax on the plane but
nothing like SSRI
no I'm a little bit I have Zoloft on my
shelf and I haven't touched it yet I
tried Lexapro a while ago I swear by
Zoloft dude yeah I have to have it man
if I don't take Zoloft then I waste so
much time in suicidal fantasies oh
really suicide audition yeah and not
like I would have not like I've ever
been anywhere near attempting suicide
it's just I just waste it oh that's good
that's good then you found your it's
just wasting time in this morbid dark
place I don't I don't need to waste time
in
so a lot when I'm taking it off that
does not happen how many milligrams 100
milligrams a day
so how long have you been doing it I've
been on Zola for almost 10 years and it
really works for you a couple times I
stopped taking it I was in uh this you
know did you start taking it when you um
what got sober were you taking it while
you weren't sober no no I I was sober I
got sober in 2008 and it and it was uh
2013 when
um I started addressing uh issues with
sexual acting out and I I went to see a
a therapist who specialized in sex
addiction and this therapist said man I
really think you uh should be on Zoloft
like you know I just get this incredible
life you know like well this uh just
built up like you know it's like you're
very anxious I just feel it radiating
off you and I think he takes off and I
was like man I'm a sober guy dude I
don't know if that that's like
one of the sober friends are on yeah
this therapist was like yeah I'm a super
guy too yeah you should get on time yeah
yeah yeah so I got on it and I I noticed
it really helped okay yeah I'm totally
done to try it I just wanted to
try you can't do psychedelics when
you're unnecessary so I wanted to do
buffo this year after my Dad's passing I
wanted to try bufo toad I wanted to try
I want to try Ayahuasca I want to try uh
I never know how to pronounce it
ibogaine evil gain I want to try all
these psychedelic remedies and then I'm
going to try the I mean we're going to
try this is all right the only thing I
worry about is like sexual side effects
like I tried Alexa Pro once and I just I
couldn't come I was with my girlfriend
in quarantine
and I tried Lexapro and we would have
sex and I was like babe I just I can't
come I can't ejaculate in my
psychiatrist is like yeah that's part of
the deal but my friend who's been on
Lexington for a while he goes that
happens at first and then your body
adjusts and you stood and now I come he
just had a kid he's like I definitely
got my [__] has created life so
um I think Zoloft is probably not yes
that that is a thing it never affected
me that much you know not that big of a
deal I think it just varies person to
person
yeah totally and I think like I just
don't want to um
take benzos too often
I would never wanna
the development addiction event so
that's that's hell on Earth but Zoloft
isn't the same as like this right it's
not a benzo loves the SSRI yeah yeah you
can't take Zoloft it's almost like
Prozac you can't take it like a Xanax is
a tranquilizer essentially you take it
in an immediate effect it tranquilizes
you SSR is you have to build up in your
system and you don't you don't really
take them like a recreational drug right
right yeah it's not going to work like
uh when you take it you gotta it's like
a half-life kind of a thing and you got
to be consistent with it yeah and it's
on a party drug you're just like slowly
it slowly builds up in you so that your
mood is elevated out of depression and
anxiety versus a Xanax which is just it
was basically the same thing as alcohol
yeah it's alcohol in a pill right so it
suppresses your uh Gaba receptor which
is responsible for anxiety and then why
are there blackouts of Xanax like so so
the same Pathways your grab receptor
and somebody online will be able to say
this a lot more articulated than I am
not a doctor but like your Gaba receptor
is responsible for memory converting
short-term memory to long-term memory
and anxiety just that your brain uses
the same pathway just your brain's
trying to be efficient and they combine
some highways are combined they have
dual function or multiple functions I
like your dick shoots out different
stuff yeah your addictions.com so your
Gaba receptor is responsible for anxiety
and it's responsible for short-term
memory converting to long term so that's
why when you drink you brown out in
black out and when you take Xanax you
you brown it on Blackout because you're
you're tampering with
um the same receptor that's responsible
for memory yeah I just remember watching
a video of this kid he woke up in jail
on like a triple homicide ate a bunch of
Xanax drank beer [__] murdered a lot
of people you don't remember that's a
zygotic person is that like I drink a
bunch of Xanax I've eaten a bunch of
Xanax and drink a bunch of beer and I
didn't go in a [__] murder spray yeah
that's true I guess you don't murder
people if you're not a murderer yeah a
murderer murders yeah no it just reduces
your anxiety but alcohol and and benzos
are uh basically the exact same thing
the benzos are like a pill form of
alcohol my MDMA therapist broke it down
my MDMA therapist that's great broke it
down he broke it down that's great yeah
but it just said couldn't sleep on the
Zoloft thing
um started in 2013 and then uh
two years later I am like was it was in
a fairly short-lived relationship with
somebody who was uh aggressively opposed
to the idea of uh like that kind of
medication yeah and while in that
relationship I just stopped taking it
cold turkey yeah yeah and then when I
stopped taking Zoloft like boom night
and day that the difference was just so
Stark like uh back into this dark morbid
yeah yeah morbidden things just crappy
miserable Place yeah if it works for you
it works for you if you and then I
started taking it again night and day
that all went away so I've had the
experience like going back and forth and
back and forth and the compulsive
Behavior to subsided
that I mean that's kind of like a
different thing like the ruminating
thoughts like you know because it's all
related to anxiety depression and
obsessive compulsive thoughts intrusive
thoughts yeah so I don't know like I
mean like Scott said everybody's
different you know I'm not a doctor but
God damn my personal experience I
have to have Zoloft yeah great now you
see yourself being on Zola for the rest
of your life I think that's how it works
yeah yeah some some say that like you
can this is what psychiatrists told me
they were like you can be on an SSRI as
long as you need it so you can be on it
for three months if you're in a rough
patch you've been out for three years or
you'll be on it for 30 years it's just
totally up too it's just my case was
what yeah I just don't even want to test
the waters yeah yeah no that makes sense
yeah do you like shopping on Amazon I do
and good news is Stevo's butt wipes for
your butt hole are available on Amazon
and if you want a real bundle of a deal
you can get Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole plus Stephen's butthole
destroyer and Stevo's butt wipes for
your butthole it's the butthole bundle
available on Amazon right now
yeah dude